los argentinos vuelven a las urnas este
domingo 14 de noviembre eligen un nuevo
congreso en estas elecciones se
renovarán 127 de los 257 escaños de la
cámara de diputados y 24 de las 72
sillas del senado si se repite el
resultado de las primarias del
oficialismo del presidente alberto
fernández perdería la mayoría en el
legislativo
los opositores juntos por el cambio
lograron algo más del 40 por ciento de
los votos mejorando su desempeño
electoral la participación de los
jóvenes el grupo más aquejado por la
crisis económica podría afectar el
kirchnerismo en las universidades que
seguimos se retrajo bastante y en las
elecciones da la impresión que otros
candidatos que apenas de voto joven
sobre todo el candidato de nueva derecha
tienen más éxito sobre todo en la zona
urbana de unos seres y los alrededores
la inflación otro gran problema en
argentina llega a más del 37 por ciento
para este año podría llegar al 48 por
ciento la segunda más alta en la región
después de venezuela mientras el
gobierno intenta frenarlo de unos 1.650
productos entre los que están lácteos
paladar y a congelados y bebidas el país
enfrenta una pobreza del
46% a pesar de que fernández aún tiene
dos años para cambiar el rumbo de
argentina es posible que sea más difícil
lograrlo si pierde terreno en las
elecciones del congreso del domingo
donde están convocados a votar más de 34
millones de personas